This course has four parts.
Just now, you're going to lay
the foundations by training your first
simple model entirely end-to-end.
For that, we'll need to talk
about logistic classification,
stochastic optimization and
general data practices to train models.
In the next session,
we're going to go deeper.
You'll train your first deep network and
you'll also learn to
apply regularization techniques
to train even bigger models.
The third session will be a deep dive
into images and convolutional models.
The fourth session, all about text and
sequences in general.
We'll train embeddings and
recurrent models.
This is going to be
a very hands-on course.
The assignments are IPython notebooks
that you can read and modify easily.
Play with them and try things out.
We will use them alongside the lectures
to make everything you will
hear about very concrete.
All the code will be
written in TensorFlow,
a very simple Python-based
deep learning toolkit.
By the time you are done
with these lectures,
you'll be able to apply all
this knowledge to new problems
entirely by yourself with
a handful of lines of code.